le tamis cialis a été pour la vie de la
plupart d'entre eux c'est celle là que
ça a commencé dans le carrousel dans
leur caisse qu'à bruxelles avec des
parents et puis comme je dis le crucial
de la vie
on rentre dans une formation décembre
par votre pont voilà on passait d'un
truc à l'autre montrent en 10 ans on
arrête après on remonte et et puis
injouable en tout cas russel métaux
russel va continuer à coeur parce que on
a déjà deux millions et même le j'avais
peur de la mise en scène on a pris ce
truc de permis c'est à dire avec une
équipe qui rendent douanes ils sont
attirants
trois ans
son joli petit jeu
soulagé
soit
les chants voulu les jolies ritournelles
on
toutes les vedettes qui vont venir se
met son défi à valois pour enfants dont
les musiciens on va mettre en valeur le
la photo le nom et en valais indienne ya
6 et après à une fois ne l'a repris le
goût du partage des retrouvailles de la
fête du vrai sega d'ouvrir la vraie
musique longtemps d'un côté nous laissa
pas là maintenant je n'ai pas savoir est
à nous
là
mais bon
ça y est